SMIL al rahman al rahim and hamdulillahi
[Arabic recitation]
rasulillah Ramallah early he was happy
wa ala alihi wa sahbihi ajma'in I'm a
bad welcome everybody thank you very
much brothers and sisters guests for
joining me today or this evening if you
will in our first installment of the
course on the book zeidel mad
the hadith a la bete authored by Sheikh
al-islam even I am Al josiya rahim
[Arabic recitation]
before we get started I would to
point something out and that is that as
I'm speaking you may find that I'm a
little bit not distracted but slightly
slightly not as I usually am then when
I'm giving a speech and the reason for
that is that I am not used to speaking
to a camera I'm used to speaking to a
crowd I've been lecturing for about 15
years now and been very successful at it
at Hyundai lab but this is my first time
only speaking to a camera so you'll have
to bear with me as I acclimate myself to
this new this new medium today and shall
lo - ila we are going to be speaking
about Zed in my ayat if you had your
clay given a bet and we're going to be
speaking about this book's author first
we want to speak about the author and we
want to speak about the book itself it's
important for us to know the author of
any book that we read it's very
important it's crucial and this is
something that many people skip a lot of
times there are introductions are so the
scholars of Islam throughout history
throughout the centuries have made it a
habit that they will write usually a
an introduction to their books even if
it is a brief one and some have much
longer introductions some introductions
are so long that they are independently
a book in there on their own such as
hediye SETI which is the first volume of
fettle body the explanation of sahih
al-bukhari it's an entire book on its
own as well the Mook edema of even
khaldoon
on history it's actually known as the
introduction to his book on Islamic
history in world history and it's
actually an entire book on its own but
it is very common for people to get a
little bit anxious and jump right into
the book before reading the introduction
and before reading about the author if
you are new to this person's work and
this is not correct and the reason for
that is the way a person writes the
things that this person says oftentimes
are contextual and the context and the
backdrop of what this person is writing
and trying to convey to us is going to
be who this person is what their
background is what school of thought
they come from etc etc likewise the
introduction to the book I have seen
somebody I have seen that a person can
completely misunderstand the entirety of
the book simply by skipping the
introduction so we are going to begin
and shallow tada
with discussing the author of Zed
Almighty the author of Zed Ahmad is a
well-known scholar most of us have heard
of him many of us have read some of his
works his works have been translated
into many languages and he has very very
popular well-known books in English that
are abundant in America and in the West
which
we'll discuss insha'Allah we are
speaking about evening camera he Mahalo
now his full name is Muhammad even sad
his cornea is you know Abu foolin or on
foolin is Abu Abdullah and his nickname
is shamsid-deen shamsid-deen he is
formerly known as Abu Abdullah
[Arabic recitation]
from Adam SP l ma roof ribbon km/l
josiya ow
Abdul kayum artists oven his father's
name was sad and his father's kunia is
Abu Bakr so sometimes you will hear even
Opium's
name as mohammed IBN ABI bakr and if no
Kim's father was a scholar of Islam and
very well acquainted with the sciences
of inheritance and fraud and actually if
no kam learned the science of
inheritance from his father who was
actually his first teacher and his
father lived in Damascus in Syria and he
actually was the principal of a school
in an Islamic school which taught
Islamic law that was known as al josiya
and madrasah to Joe Zia and this school
he was so well known and such a fixture
of the landscape of this school and he
was so influential in maintaining this
school he was later given the nickname
Khayyam al josiya the principal or the
maintainer or the super if you will of
and josiya school and so by extension
his son Muhammad became known as even ke
Josie the son of the principal of Al
Joseon and sometimes he is referred to
as even LPM the son of the principal or
eben km/l josiya the principal of a
josiya often times a little side note
there is a mistake that is made people
will say even
lkm and Joe Zia that is incorrect if you
say I banal km/l Joe Zia
you have made the name of the school one
of his descriptions if you will
grammatically it is wrong it is either
even L p.m. or even km l josiya if no km
Rahim a whole law was born in the year
691 691 and this is a very very
interesting time to be born why is that
because it bridges to very great eras
together 691 you have the era of the
600's the late 6th century after hijra
the early 7th century after Hitler this
is when a team M&O Elahi mahalo even
malik and many other very well-known
scholars were in the mush Damascus in
Syria at the time and it was a hotbed of
learning Islamic Sciences people came
all the way from the far reaches of the
known world at the time
as far as Spain to learn in dementia and
often scholars came from such for our
faraway lands to teach in domestic so
Syria and a sham at that time was the
the lighthouse and beacon of Islamic
knowledge at the time also we have the
era of the we have the era of the other
scholars that came during this
time which were known as the scholars
that kind of rejuvenated Islamic
knowledge and and refined it and
reiterated it in a time when it was
becoming obscured by the opinions of men
and that is the time of event amelia
rahim allah even Cathy of Shem sadena
the heavy element Mizzy and all of these
others and so on okay ma ma Allah he was
born in this time he was born in on the
seventh day of the month of Safa year
six is 691 he began learning from his
father his father said Abu Bakr al play
Yemen josiya and he learned from him
most notably the sciences of inheritance
Abdul kayum rahim allah from a very very
young age began to study and when I say
young I mean as young as five years old
he was known to begin to memorize works
and books of scholars of his time and
this is not something which is
unfathomable it may be strange to us in
our time but even lamo him Allah is
obviously very very unique he is an
exceptional mind that only come about
every now and then in human history
if Nilayam rahim allah really began to
seek knowledge officially in the year
697 so that puts us at six years old he
began to seek knowledge and when he
started to learn about his land he
became more and more enthusiastic and
even Okayama rahim allah continued to
learn until he came in contact with his
most notable scholar and the one who
would have the most effect on the way he
thought
and the way he viewed Islamic knowledge
and even the way that he viewed the
world and that is Shakeel Islam event
[Arabic recitation]
even Tamiya he passed away in the year
728 after Hitler even okay rahim allah
met Cheryl Islam even Tamia
and the year 712 so they roughly spent
about 16 years together no ka maha Maha
law was known to be his most close
confidant and he would be with even
Tamiya everywhere and he spent those 16
years and you know it now pay him at
that time was about 22 years old when he
met even Tamiya rahimullah and he spent
the next 16 years with Shaquille it's
never been Tamiya and Sheikh al-islam
even Tamiya had a profound effect on
[Arabic recitation]
is such a prominent figure and if no
claims works that whenever we see if no
km say Kailash a Huna or our sheikh said
or our teacher said or Sheikh al-islam
said he is referring to even Tamia rahim
allah if nope am preserved a lot of a
lot of nice little nuggets of wisdom and
benefits from event ami al rahim allah
that we really can't find elsewhere
which he mentions a lot through his
books and especially in Zedan ayat he
makes mention of even Tamia a lot
another one of his scholars and hadith
even Tamiya was most influential on an
even opium in al-qaeda and in effect
these are where these are the two fields
creed and jurisprudence that even my
yamaja mala picked up a lot of and was
influenced by even Tamiya very much
another one of his scholars most notable
teachers was an amendment Mizzy raha
mahalo Todd
l ms Z is actually even Cathy's
father-in-law right so even Cathy R is
one of him no km students as well which
will get you and Lizzie was one of
ethnic Williams teachers and Missy is
known to be the most knowledgeable man
in the science of hadith in his era
there was not known to be anyone more
knowledgeable than an imam and Mizrahi
Mahalo to Allah and the science of
hadith during his time and he was such a
profound scholar of hadith that all of
the names found in the six main books of
hadith sahih al-bukhari so here Muslim
serenity remedies on an everyday would
suggest any Sonnen an essay and soon any
bin major he had which are thousands of
men he had memorized every one of their
names their dates of birth and dates of
death how many children they have who
they heard from who their teachers were
and that's what he specialized in about
him a whole law it's mentioned that lmmm
izia rahim Ahola was so had such mastery
in the science of hadith that he would
sit in his chair to give his with his
students and the way they would do it at
the time was they would take their books
that the students that they had written
and gathered their narrations in and
they would read them to William and
Mizrahi mahalo and he would affirm that
their narrations are correct and the
wordings are correct and the names are
placed properly and he would give them
their ijazat at that time and this is
how they did it but Minzy over him Allah
had a habit of falling asleep during
these sessions so he'd be sitting in his
chair and he would fall asleep
and the students you know they would
continue to read clearly he's sleeping
and subhanAllah even in his sleep if the
students would make a mistake in the
wording or make a mistake in the name of
one of the narrator's and Mozilla
heimola would come to attention and
correct him this is how well ingrained
the science of hadith was in the mind of
an MS ysou he was known to fall asleep
during class when giving class and he
was also known to be giving class even
in his sleep Rahim a low tide so an imam
is e is even kathira s-- father in law
and he had the biggest influence on him
don't pay him and even kaffir in the
science of hadith and rightfully so when
you hear even Cathy Rin in his tough CSA
our chef said he's speaking about that
Missy
Rehema hole I usually for a ruling on a
hadith living Cathy --is mother-in-law
was his teacher or one of his teachers
in the recitation of the Quran so he
took some of his high sn8 chains of
narration to the prophets all alone he
was seldom of the hold on from his
mother-in-law and this is the kind of
this is the kind of environment they
were in I mean if we imagine that our
in-laws would teach us hadith and the
Quran this is Gianni obviously there's a
disparity between that's which is going
on today and that which is then but this
is how it was in the time of having
Cathy Avraham Allah and so these are his
most influential Shia of course he heard
from many many scholars but these three
are the most influential the ones who
had the biggest impact on his life and
on his thought and on his methodology
and his understanding of his limb and
that is his father his first year Abu
Bakr
likewise his second Shaykh
even Tamiya and that is his main teacher
and also elite my name is Ibrahim Al on
the science of hadith he also has a lot
of notable students and will mention a
few of them whom we we will know as soon
as we hear their name and we may never
have heard that these are actually of no
claim students one of them is a barrage
of at ham Bunny about him all alone
Rajab and ham buddy who has the very
famous known explanation on the 40
narrations of an amendment now what we
jamming our lumi with Hickam bill Rajab
and humbly is one of if no poems
students and he actually listened and
recited even Opium's knew Nia in the
science of Creed and al-qaeda
more than six thousand verses also even
Cathy the great more festive visib no
poems students and actually it was his
most he was his most notable student he
was the one who was closest to him and
he was his very close confidant he spent
much time with him no Kiyomori Mahalo
another is Ali mama Debbie Rahim Ahola
that B is the great scholar of history
Islamic history and the great scholar of
hadith Lee mama the hability mellow to
either was also one of the millions
students also been Abdel heady
the great scholar of Felina pita as well
and so these are some of his most
notable students and if you look at this
you see that you cannot separate these
individuals you can't separate these
individuals you cannot and this is
something that we see we see a
oftentimes a lot of misconceptions
around event a me or him hola a lot of
people a lot of people kind of
recoil from moving Tamia but they love
him they'll pay him and you can't really
separate the two they are two sides to
the same coin even okay I'm an event a
meal rahim allah are inseparable in this
life and it shall learn the hereafter
also even Cathy even Cathy avahi Mahalo
is part of that school of thought that
great school of thought and they all
followed the most of the opinions of
shaquille Islam even Tamia rahim allah
tala i want to mention some of the books
that Evan okay Liam has written and when
we mentioned some of these books we will
actually learn a lot about who he is and
how knowledgeable he was I am a low tide
if no claim when I saved no claim most
people think of spirituality this is
Howard no claim is viewed especially to
the english-speaking masses because a
lot of what is unique about it no km are
his spiritual his spiritual writings
very poetic and he delves into issues
that explain a lot to us about the world
of the unseen and even if am about him
Allah was very very skilled at this
obviously and he had a lot of insight
into the secrets and the nuances of the
Quran and the Sunna which we will see in
sha allah al rahim allah has many many
books in almost every field you can
think of and unfortunately most not most
but many of his books are lost and we
don't have them anymore just the same as
we have with even Cathy the same as we
have with a heavy the same that we have
with Abell Rajab the same that we have
with even Tamiya many of their books are
lost why are there books lost well we
have to understand how book
were written at the time and we have to
understand the political climate at the
time books were written in that the time
where a shed wishes to write a book for
instance let's say even Tamiya wants to
write a book or have no claim or anyone
the way that this would happen is is
usually one of two ways number one they
would either write the book themselves
they would write it with their hand
penned a book and then they would give
it to their students to make copies of
it and these students would give it to
their students to make more copies of it
and this process would continue and it
may take a hundred years for a
particular book written in a particular
land to reach the far out lands far away
in this process but if the scholar was
very very famous very popular such as a
bubbly and nella we even Tamiya even lkm
these people have been Cathy if they
they would write a book and these books
would reach out to the four furthest
corners of the earth within a couple of
years and this is considered a great
feat at a time another way that they
would write the book is they would sit
down and they would dictate what they
have to say to their students and their
students would write it this is how for
example of bubbly of allah allah wrote
his books
Autobody the Great Wolf s suit would sit
and he would begin to mention a verse of
the Quran and begin to make his Stef's
Eve and his students would be there
writing this is why we have disparities
in the in the different copies of the
book the the book may have two or three
copies two or three different students
one would miss a word here one would
exchange one word with the synonym etc
and so we would have slight variations
in these books
well these variations throughout time
may become more and more and this is
where the science of Italia comes in
which is when we take many copies of one
book and we try to make one complete
book as close to what we know the author
intended as possible now we see that
this process is a very lengthy process
but it was a beneficial process because
a person can only acquire books one of
two ways you either go to the library
and you write and make a copy of the
book yourself which is extremely
time-consuming or you pay someone to
make a copy of the book so you ones
added my ID you go to a cup fault and
you say look I need a copy of Zed in my
head you pay him whatever you pay him
and six months later your copy of Zed
and my ID is ready this is how books
were and so only the best of the best of
books went through this process but the
enemies of even Tamia owe him a law even
they'll pay him what they did was they
started to purchase these books and burn
them to get rid of them and you know if
there's only five copies of the book and
you hunt down four of them and burn them
and there's only one copy left you know
very easy to get rid of books at that
time you know now we have them in hard
drives and so forth but it wasn't like
this at the time there weren't thousands
and thousands of copies of one book it
was just a few copies throughout the
Muslim land I want to mention something
being that we're speaking about have no
claim and evidence a media I want to
address this misconception about even
Tamia rahim allah now one of the ways
that we know a person of greatness is
the reaction of other people right so
for example the Prophet Muhammad SAW
along our newest enemy not only was he
such a profound man but look at the
reaction that his words had in his time
and all the way till now till the end of
the
world right he becomes the center focus
of things and this is oftentimes a
hallmark of greatness that a scholar is
able to write a book even if they have a
lot of critics that's okay because in
order to have a lot of critics you have
to be in in your critics field of view
you have to be they have to be giving
you attention for criticism and it bent
a me over him a whole la most of what he
said and differed with with his peers
who actually if you read his story he
was actually persecuted a lot most of
the things that he differed with them on
what were issues that they would agree
with him had they liked him as a person
this is a statement that a verbal him
Allah mentioned in his sila of event
amia you have to remember that when
peers speak of each other these are
human beings right so there are
instances where one scholar may speak of
another and there is an element if they
are peers there is an element of
competition there right and scholars are
not infallible there can be instances of
jealousy we see what happened with use
of a dataset M and his brothers and this
is not something that we are that we are
completely free of we are always human
and so there will be that element it is
very dulled and it is very controlled
and mitigated in the hearts of scholars
who are true servants of Allah subhana
Allah but sometimes it is there even
Tamiya Rehema who law was the kind of
scholar that was one in a billion
he had a very very sharp mind
he was extreme
well-read and he was almost impossible
to defeat in debate and these traits
here breed a lot of jealousy
they breed a lot of jealousy and so a
lot of his critics a lot of it was
jealousy there was a lot of that
involved another thing is that even
Tamiya rahamallah was a wonderful person
very generous very hospitable but in the
field of debate or the sciences he was a
completely different person
right even Shem sadena they have a mole
of one of his students this story and he
wrote a biography on it ami a very very
well-written biography and it was
actually lost for many years and it has
been rediscovered in some obscure
library and has been brought and seen
the day light of day recently in the
last 10 years and Shem sadena Davila he
Mahalo he mentioned about even Tamiya he
said kana yolk cream ooh were you here
no fin f-cell modulus that even Tamiya
raha Mahalo he would honor you and also
come off as smug and belittle you in the
same sitting what does that mean well as
a person when you would sit with him he
is a very hospitable person with very
good character yet the way that he sees
things so clearly if a debate on a
particular issue would occur you may
feel you may feel that he comes off as
condescending that was not his intention
at all obviously and so even Tamiya
Rehema who law was extremely well
focused in debate very Mahalo described
him as KN who lathe help he was almost
a
Ayana of war in debate he was very very
focused and very aggressive in debate
and this breeded a lot of contempt and
jealousy Shem sadena they about him oh
Allah he mentioned a statement which I
found very interesting he said if in
more or less words he said if even
taymiyah had practice a little mood
Allah for his critics if he had
practiced a little bit of appeasement
for his critics right a little
give-and-take with his critics and if he
had been a little more gentle in the way
that he spoke in the way that he
articulated his opinions CAD any Hakuna
Kelly meta is Mehra he would have been
agreed upon and he would have been
agreed with across the board no one
could have disagreed with him had that
been the case a lot of the debates a lot
of the things that lasted they are
personal issues they are personal issues
from his peers and I want my brothers
and sisters and West who understand this
not just not not everything someone says
about another person is automatically
true an objective there's a lot of
subjectivity there even taemi about him
a hello to Iowa's differed with and if
you look for a problem you will often
find one now what does that mean a
person may be jealous of another person
a person may be feel guilt 'add by
another person and so if they are in the
if they are scholars they will look to
justify this from a religious or
scholarly standpoint and so they will
kind of spiritualize their crusade or
their vendetta and so what ends up
happening is we start having refutations
of things which really should
not be an issue of contention an issue
of debate or we have refutations of them
fighting over semantics right this
wording means this and tit for tat and
this oftentimes is fueled by jealousy
and that is why in the science of hadith
one of the disciplines is learning how
to identify jealousy between peers and
it has happened where one scholar of
hadith will will actually refute another
and it's not common I don't want it to
be as if this is something that
happens all the time and the scholars of
Islam are just these Jill no this is not
the case but it does happen
and learning to identify these issues is
very crucial
so even Okayama rahim allah has a few
books that he has written that are very
influential one of those books is madad
aegis any keen vain amenaza ve yakin abu
do what ya canister in this is a book
that he wrote regarding the very deep
spiritual aspect of our worship and
journey to allah subhanahu wata'ala and
in this book he had mentioned different
phases or levels that a person goes
through different phases and levels of
worship that a person will go through on
his journey to salvation and learning
about a loss of hano it's at a very
profound book another is most active
USADA and this is a book which is
regarding the rubia of allah subhanahu
wata'ala and that is the actions of
allah and there is a lot of reflection
in this book about the creation of the
heavens and the earth and and so forth
and there's a lot of dispelling that he
does in this book of different
philosophical debates and debates of
logic and
he discusses mythology and he discusses
he discusses superstition and he gets
into this very deeply very profound book
as well another of his books that is
very very well-known is
[Arabic recitation]
billah' de la fois is a complete
description of paradise according to the
quran and sunnah from beginning to end
also he has other books such as jelly FM
facility was salam ala muhammadin soul
alone and he was seldom Clairol NM which
is a book all about the virtues of
making a slowly upon the prophets all
alone on us alien al job with Kathy Lee
Vance Elana Dawa Chevy also known as a
debt with the weather this is a book
that is known informally as the illness
the ailment and the cure this book is
actually a fete with that's all the book
is somebody sent him a question which
was about a paragraph long the gist of
the question is are share a man is it
tries to be a good person he has a sin
that he continues to do he knows that
this sin is wrong he wishes to leave it
off and he understands that this sin
will mark his destruction in this life
and the hereafter but he continues to do
this sin and it is eating him up what is
the problem why can't he leave it off
and even don't claim about him Allah
writes this fatwa which has actually
turned into a very lengthy book over 200
pages
what if no claim is not known for with
many people he's known for this with the
scholars but he is not known for this
with the general masses and that is his
knowledge in the science of hadith and
this really shows in two of his books
tatoeba sunan certain everyday wood and
another book at Manabe moon 'if fee mad
if at the sahi what life these two books
we see just how deep his knowledge runs
in the science of hadees very profound
and he has other books Eva that'll
FN which speaks entirely about all of
the methods that a shape on employs in
order to take the human being astray
very influential book as well the book
that we're going to speak about today is
is that the mad and this is the book
that we are going to be having this
series on to finish up we're going to
give a little bit about this book
Zedan mad literally translates to
provisions for the appointment
provisions for the appointments
what is the appointment meaning the day
when we meet a loss of Hannah without at
the appointed time the appointed meeting
with allah rabbul aalameen when we will
be brought before him and judged Sahana
by him soprano
wa tada and so allah subhana wa ta'ala
said in the quran what isaiah doofah in
the hey rosy table and take provisions
for your journey and the best of
provisions is righteousness this is what
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala has mentioned in
the in the Quran in surah al-baqarah
discussing Hajj now notice here when he
discussed Hajj in the Quran in surah
al-baqarah
he said Weta's alwa doofah in the hi
rosita pwah he said and take provisions
for your journey meaning to Hajj in this
life and the best of provisions for the
bigger picture the greatest of journeys
is righteousness for your true journey
that you were upon as a human being and
that is your journey to the meeting of a
loss of hano Tata and so if no km wrote
this book on his way to hedge this is
when he wrote this book and he wrote
this book from memory and he named this
book Zaid almight in accordance with
that verse he named this book the
provisions for the appointed day so this
book acts as provisions of how to
express our taqwa of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala on our journey to salvation he
wrote this book from memory and he
dedicated this book to the prophets all
alone you assailed him what I mean by
dedicated meaning dedicated the subject
of the book to the Prophet Muhammad SAW
Allah on you ascending so this book is
actually a very lengthy book it's
usually five volumes in its original
form and a lot of the things that if
Nilayam says a lot of the treaties that
we see that are printed and little books
that are printed they're actually
derived from zetton mahad their chapters
or parts that are taken out and
independently published one very namely
portion is the fourth volume of Zima ad
which is known as a benevolent never we
the prophetic medicine which is
everywhere in all languages and probably
in every house of every Muslim in
America this book is actually the fourth
volume of Zedan ayat where he discusses
the way that the prophet sallallaahu
salem would treat illnesses of the heart
of the mind in the body
Zaid Ahmad has other portions but really
Zedan mod follows a rough a rough kind
of a rough order okay it's written from
memory so it's not he kind of wrote it
as he felt so it's not in a really
strict order it's kind of loosely in a
particular order and that rough order is
he begins with describing the prophets
all alone on you ascend him the way that
he dressed the way that he spoke the way
that he walked the way that he sat the
way that he eats what colors he liked
what colors he didn't what he liked
to eat what he didn't to eat how
would he eat how would he wash his face
and then he gets into the five pillars
of Islam he speaks about the Prophet SAW
alone I never said I'm sorry he speaks
about zakah he speaks about fasting he
speaks about Hajj these are the first
two volumes of Zed
night the third volume of ZMOT discusses
the biography of the Prophet sallallaahu
said the fourth volume discusses the
prophetic medicine right and the fifth
volume is discussing the judgments of
the prophet sallallaahu said anytime he
passed the judgement the circumstances
of that judgment now we're going to be
covering just basically skimming the
surface of this if we were to go through
the entire book in detail we would be
sitting here for 20 years
this is not something it's a very very
lengthy book however we are going to go
roughly with we're going to touch on the
main most important points of the book
in a very very summarised fashion why
this book there are many books on this
subject why this book the reason is is
that this book if no kalium gave us
exactly why he wrote this book and what
the point of this book is he mentions in
the introduction of Zedan Mahad that
this book is dedicated to the way that
the prophets Allah law and it was in
them did things we are not discussing
the difference of opinion amongst
scholars of Islam on individual issues
this is not what the subject of the book
is about the subject of the book is what
the prophets all alone on you asylum was
narrated to have done to have said to
have affirmed this is the subject of the
book and he mentions that the scholars
play an important role in the guidance
of humanity and that role he mentions is
similar to the role of the stars if we
wish to make Salah and we are going to
basically end with this and next week
insha'Allah we are going to begin the
actual book he gives us a parable he
says the scholars of Islam are the
stars of the sky if we wish to know the
direction of prayer which direction the
Kaaba is
and we cannot see the Kaaba we look to
the Stars and we get a direction however
if the Kaaba is in front of us there is
no need to look to the Stars anymore
this is this this is the example that
have no claim or Humalog gifts not every
time we see the prophets alone on your
seldom said or did we need to go back
and make sure that the scholars are okay
with that this is backwards this is not
the way that the scholars of Islam
intended their works to be viewed the
scholars of a snap guide us through
those things which are uncertain to us
but are certain to them because they
have a higher view the stars in the
sky they can see the whole picture we
can't but when the Kaaba is in front of
us we no longer need those stars for
that which is most apparent and so this
is what the subject of this book is and
this is why this book is so important he
wrote it completely from memory he so he
reference more than two hundred
different books from memory and he
mentioned almost every aspect of the
prophets Allah law and he was in his
life that has ever been narrated and
mentioned almost all of his statements
and narrations all from memory and this
shows us the amazing wealth of knowledge
that have no claim on him old law was
bestowed with by Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
so next week in sha allah we will begin
our journey with even Alohomora him o
allah ends at the night he had a favor
that thank you very much for
joining us today
we ask Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala that he
teach us of his book what we are
ignorant of and that he remind us of it
what we have been made to forget and
that he benefit us from that which he
[Arabic recitation]
while he was high Viet Minh but hamdu
lillahi rabbil a Denis